thanks for everyone coming to the
afternoon session
hope you're not too sleepy
um
let's uh go ahead and begin um greta is
going to be telling us about the chronic
chronic coefficients of the symmetric
group and complexity and counter torques
thank you very much
um
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak here at simon's once again
once again about the chronic your
coefficients but this time
hopefully there will be some new results
and a
slightly different point of view
and uh
before i before i uh
start with the talk i just must i don't
say that i don't see what's happening on
zoom so we don't have this on the
screens here so if you have any
questions
and you're watching on zoom please shout
out
okay
so
so
what is this what's the story
about the story with the chronic your
coefficient starts
with uh
very simple combinatorial and algebraic
objects the symmetric group which is
just
the group of permutations which are just
bijections from one end to one end and
we view them as a group under
permutation composition
um
and then we can we have uh
other major objects
that are going to be used throughout the
talk these are the integer partitions
and they will show up in uh in
representation serious uh weights
and their uh highest weights they are uh
just integers
decreasing
sequence of intent non non-negative
integers that sum up to n and we draw
them with young diagrams in terms of
boxes
so
so what are presentations so there were
mentioned already a few times implicitly
um let me just uh explain this
very briefly so that we have some idea
what i might what i'm talking about
so the representations of in in this
case the symmetric group
and in general there are group
homomorphisms of from this group to the
general linear group or in other words
ways of
representing the group elements as
matrices so that they the matrices would
obey the same rules as the group
elements
and one
classical way of representing matrices
for example is the permutation matrix so
one
for example this permutation 231 would
go to this permutation matrix
so this is a representation
once we have this construction we want
to know
uh what are the invariant spaces or in
other words
how do we
[Music]
decompose it into irreducible so
the reducible representations would be
the minimal
uh
sn invariant subspaces and they would
decompose into direct
um
direct sum our vector space so for
example for this representation we have
that
there are actually two irreducible
representations you can verify
immediately that
the vector space spanned by the vector 1
1 1 or these are the elementary basis
vectors c 1 e 2 and 3 this is
um
this is an invariant space and here is
the other one
and we we have this is classic these are
called classical hundred year old
results that we know how to characterize
uh these reducible representations of
the symmetric group and all actually
also the general linear group using the
exactly these guys these partitions
and uh the
my older
uh the reducible representations of the
symmetric group are in one to one
correspondence with
the integer partitions of n and in
particular there so there is a way of
identifying them and the trivial
representation is just
one row partition
and this guy here is the partition two
one
so here's trust
okay
so
um so a little bit more background
before i can define the main players
the more background is so the characters
of the symmetric the this s and your
irreducible representations
uh if we take our matrix
for each particular element we can take
the trace
and uh
and then this so in this particular
example the trace is going to be minus
one
and uh for for a given representation
the traces of the elements actually
define determine the representation
uniquely
thanks to various properties the
orthogonality of characters and so on so
instead of dealing with the whole
matrices of the representation we can
deal with the characters
so these are
the character chi of the reducible
representation indexed by lambda
evaluated at
the conjugacy class
alpha so
conjugacy classes in the symmetric group
are given by the cycle type
decomposition of the permutation
and they can be computed with a
combinatorial rule which is however from
complexity point of view is as horrible
as you want
because this is an alternating sum over
mourinho yamato blow which i'll give you
an example in a moment
and then
so it's minus one to the height of the
table so we have no idea
actually what how many terms here cancel
and so on
and uh here is one example this is a
morning gamma kayamata blow is just a
way of cutting our table into ribbons
of given length so the lengths are the
type of the tableau the second partition
they add up the block has to be weakly
increasing along rows and down columns
and and the height is determined by the
height of these ribbons
and so in this particular example
there are two so here are two examples
one case we get minus one in the other
case we get 0 as a character
so
so in some sense everything i'm going to
to say now can be combinatorially
defined with these formulas forgetting
about the algebra but this is not
very helpful
and
so now once we have discussed
we have characterized the reducible
representation the next natural question
is to study multiplicities
multiplicities in the tensor products
of irreducible representation so i'm
gonna start with something that you're
probably more familiar with since
so people work with the
general linear group
the reducible representations are again
indexed by by partitions this time the
partitions are just have
fixed finite length
bounded by n the
size of the
these matrices
and uh
if you take
tensor product like they
from neumann started doing and then
studying when studying li algebras in
the third test you can
decompose this as a reductive group so
you can the tensor product is still a
representation that we can
decompose into irreducibles with certain
multiplicities and these multiplicities
or given lambda mu and then mu are these
c lambda mu littlewood richardson
coefficients
defined by
wood and richardson in 1934
and they can be computed
so i'm stating this is a theorem in
1934 but it actually took
maybe 20 or more years to actually prove
that this is actually
going to be the
rule so they are equal to the number of
certain types of tableau
skew shape
new over mu and thai plant
i also count integer points in a
specific
the hive polytope so
this is another way of describing it so
this
i'm not gonna go into the details of the
rule but basically you trust me that
we're counting structures
structures like this
and
this is a sharpie formula
if if we want to
put it in a complexity perspective
so
which is
exactly
what we have here so if we have the
problem lr which is to compute the value
of this little richardson coefficient
this is a
by because of this rule we can prove
that this is in sharp p
and if we want to decide whether the
little richardson coefficient is
strictly positive so not equal to zero
it's so it's actually a small miracle
thanks to the saturation conjecture
proven by knutson and tell that this is
actually polynomial
um so the next thing one can do
is take the reducible representations of
the symmetry group and play the same
game so take the stanza tensor product
we have the diagonal action of sn
decomposes into irreducibles
with certain multiplicity a future
reducible representation what is this
these are our chronic your coefficients
um
and so here is here are some examples so
these two
this is uh
two irreducibles
will decompose into
each irreducible
uniquely one so each of these
coefficients is going to be one
and uh and once and it's already
hard to actually calculate any any
bigger examples um
certainly if you try to if you ask sage
to compute chronic your coefficients
you're gonna be out of luck after
maybe n
20 or something like that
uh and
and this is actually
so another way to to define them
is going back to what matthias
christendo was talking about in the
one to marginal problem
um
where you have this the in the in the
three the three dimension three
dimensions
then there are these three spaces by
sure vowel duality it decomposes into
general linear group irreducibles v
lambda v mu and we knew these tensors
and the coefficients the multiplicities
are exactly the same chronicler
coefficients
so
maybe
so so just to connect with matthias
so they they were
interested in the moment polytope
which is
for for this problem
boils down to
figuring out if for a triple
of rational rational coordinates if you
scale them
large enough by some integer and
is this strictly positive
so so
okay
inherently there is a
there is a problem already there about
chronic your coefficients
and here it's in explicit form like this
and of course the last thing is where we
can define them as an inner product of
these characters i just described
so you can in principle with pen and
paper calculate the values of the
chronicler coefficients without actually
finding the matrices but
i just said but this is a horrible
formula because as we said these
characters are
are
alternating sums of exponentially large
objects
um
and so what do we know about computation
of this quantities
so as i said so the little richardson
coefficients are relatively nice
the characters
are basically as bad as you as as you
want and
we are
in the process of describing exactly how
bad the characters are
but just
deciding whether the character is zero
or not is an np
hard problem
and
the same thing holds for the chronic
your coefficients
again that took to calculating the
problem given our input lambda mu and
you are figuring out if they are
strictly positive
so we for the chrome we don't actually
know whether this is in sharp p we only
know that's a gap p so it's difference
of two sharpie functions
that's the best we know on the other
hand we know there are no negative
integers from the representation here
so
is this in sharp p or not that's
actually the big problem in the
complexity world
and deciding whether they're posit
positive is an np-hard problem
which is a recent result by christian
nikki and marquette moment mikhail
walter
okay
so in some sense
that's the complexity so now what well
okay so
yeah
i guess
are they
is it sharp part
even if they have maybe not the hr yeah
it's a sharpie
ah so i'll i'll i'll give you some
examples later so
actually i'll give you an example right
right now which would explain why
they're sharply heard
and this is the really the example so
this is one one slide of
what's known from the combinatorial
point of view and you know people in
combinatorics were first studying these
questions
they didn't phrase this in computational
complexity terms but we're asking is
there a combinatorial interpretation so
is there some nice way of
nice nice discrete family of objects
where we say that the chronic
coefficient is equal to the number of
these objects
this is what they wanted as a
combinatorial interpretation but
formally it's exactly asking whether
this problem is sharp is
sharpie or not
and here is basically the proof that is
going to be sharpie hard because for a
very special family of partitions
you can reconstruct the little with
richardson question and the little
richardson coefficient
for another special family of partitions
who can
uh boils down to the knobs problem so
it's
sharpie
card
yeah
in all of these complexity theoretic
results you're stating what is the
precise sense of the size of the input
so so that's another very good question
so what i'm stating so far is going to
be in binary
so these partitions lambda mu and you
are sequences of integers which are
encoded in binary
in binary um and in that sense this is
this is sharpie heart however with the
chronic your coefficients and the
characters we already know that even
inputing unary
is is giving us sharpie hardness with
the little richardson coefficient this
is not exactly clear
um
but hopefully soon will be
and yeah so they would be they would be
hard in the in unary as well
and uh
so so this is this is one one reduction
and the other things that we know are
only very special cases when
so the first result came
okay the first results came in the in
the late 80s so just when two partitions
are hooks which is
then the third partition actually can be
at most a double hook in this
case so it's very very restricted
and some other special cases but overall
even the general case of having a
two-row partition and two arbitrary
partitions we don't really know
okay so
so why why do we
uh
why do we care about this little this
chronic your coefficient so one one
motivation already matthias christendor
told us about so it has to do with the
moment polytope and the quantum marginal
problem
and the other motivation has to do with
geometric complexity theory
and
so
this is always hard but let's see if i
can explain geometric complexity theory
in one slide
and of course i'm going to cheat because
i know you guys know what
mostly what this is about but uh
so already peter mentioned variance p
valiance and p problems uh this morning
so
these are
polynomials which are polynomially easy
to to calculate to calculate with them
let's say
so depending on what model of
computation we use either
branching program or
or circuits and so on so there is there
there's already already a sequence of
refinements
but roughly speaking
in a very informal way these are the
easy polynomials in the v and p are is
the algebraic version of np so these are
the difficult polynomials and and
and distinguishing these two classes v
and p and v v p and v and t boils down
to distinguishing the determinant and
the permanent in what sense in the sense
that
the determinant is a universal
polynomial
for vp
and the permanent is a
representative the permanent is a v and
p hard
so
if we show that uh
the permanent cannot be
written
so this is i'm not i don't know if you
can read this is quite small
so if the
the permanent
we are going to to look at what is the
smallest
and such that the permanent can be
written as a determinant of a
n by n matrix
with a fine linear forms
so alpha 1 1 x 1 1 plus alpha 1 2 x 1 2
and so on so
then
yeah so the permanent amps are here
so permanent n
so n is going to be some function of m
the minimum one is going to be the
determinant of complexity of this
particular polynomial
and basically
vp versus v and p boils down to showing
that
that this n is not polynomial is super
polynomial in m so
v p versus v and p
is n
bigger than
any polynomial of fixed degree in m
okay so now
okay so what is
uh the geometric complexity theory here
well
so these polynomials this particular
ones the determinant and the permanent
they exhibit symmetries
by uh
as you can see as you can see in the in
these expressions in the
coordinates we can permute the rows and
the columns
and in general the fact that all we care
about is up to some a fine linear
combination we can act with the matrices
with the general linear group on these
polynomials and we are still going to be
in the same
class of
functions so
so we
we use this
and this is uh
so basically
expressing the permanent as this a fine
linear combination
uh as is the determinant of a fine
linear matrix
we can
we might as well take the orbits acting
as
with linear forms on this on these
polynomials
so in this case the general linear group
in n squared
uh of size n squared because we have n
squared variables
so don't be confused that there are
inherent matrix n by n matrices here but
we are acting on this
on the variables of the matrix so n
squared
and
and then we can apply
if if we can write this then it means
that the permanent is in the
orbit closure of the determinant and we
can take
orbit closures on both sides and now we
are going we can talk about an algebraic
geometric object so comparing the orbit
closures
of the permanent and the determinant
polynomial
and
uh and then we can
look at uh at the ring of uh
uh
so the coordinate ring of
irregular functions on these orbit
closures
and what the gct program of malmurian
socony says that
if this inclusion of coordinate rings
holds
then we need to show that n is bigger
than polynomial polynomial in m
terms and this would immediately
disprove this
that this is uh
that this is this the other way
that the permanent is a
polynomially large determinant
so
so one way to distinguish these
coordinate rings which are
pretty large is by looking at their
decomposition into irreducible
representations again so this is these
are gln squared in variance spaces so
they are gln squared modules so we can
actually
decompose them into irreducible gland
representation just like we
we if we want to compare two to large
integers we can look at their prime
divisors and see which
there if there is a prime number which
shows up with different degree
in one versus the other so we
we can say
we can say
that one number cannot divide the other
if it has a
larger prime factor of some kind so the
same thing is here with the reducible
representations
so if we want to distinguish this
if we want to say that the permanent is
not in the determinant
then
then we need to find some partition
lambda which is going to be called an
obstruction
so for which this
the multiplicity here is smaller than
the multiplicity here
and if we
show this for n bigger than polynomial
of m then we basically get that vp is
not equal to vnp so
so this is a constructive approach so we
need to find the partition for which
this inequality holds and then we get
this stitch so
so this is the
idea of
the gct pro
and now if we want to so these
multiplicities are pretty horrible as
you can imagine
uh now since since
studying them is hard probably hard
we might as well look into whether this
multiplicity here is actually zero and
the other one is strictly positive so
that type of very simple inequality
and this is gonna be called the
occurrence obstruction
and this was a
uh
easier conjecture in the moment and
suchony program in gct that there exists
such a current substrictions that would
show that n is bigger than 40 m
and unfortunately as you probably
heard of this thing this turned out to
be false
so there are no occurrence obstructions
and then we need to look for
multiplicity abstractions which means
that we need to figure out
something more about the sizes of this
multiplicity cs
depend on this particular embedding of
permanent indeterminate where you
complete it with a diagonal
if you
had a different i mean i know that it
does depend on
yeah maybe that's a negative result
right
you were so
you are right because so well then what
i'm not saying here in in this situation
is that we are homogenizing by one
variable
to degree m so maybe
and uh but the other result
and the problem is that
we are using the determinant as a
heating model so if you want to get rid
of this you have to use the iterated
matrix multiplication and algebraic
branching programs that
then you are not going to have this
problem with the different degrees and
the embedding that
[Music]
you can consider
different descriptions
this is going to be different but i mean
this is going to stay the same right
so
so
and and you are right that the way we
disprove it is we actually do use them
okay so so so in that sense we cannot
disprove another permanent versus
another model or different level
so
just
iterated matrix multiplication like the
various obstructions are still possible
or
it's not rolled out
it's not true though
oh but
okay so with that particular structural
valve but by
so iterating matrix multiplication it's
pretty clear that's the first
obstruction sorry
so is it is it proved as well that even
with the iterative authentication is
also ruled out for
no we did not we didn't right
outside
embedded permanent
[Music]
so this so this this particular thing is
the floor of the embedding i will
explain
but in the other cases so from what we
have studied so
okay so let me just
say
go go closer to the punchline so what
was so why when i was talking about this
chronicler coefficient so far
so the chronicler coefficients lambda so
there is this partition lambda here
and and they are the two parameters d is
the degree of the regular functions
lambda and then n to the d n to the d
this is an upper bound for the delta for
the multiplicity in the determinant
and then this gamma the multiplicity in
this padded permanent
is uh
there is nothing nothing very special
about it other than that uh
only particular partitions lambda can
show up and we are just bounding it by
the multiplicity in the whole ring of
degree d polynomials in n variables
which is what
what this
what this is in the end
and this is just the platysm coefficient
so we actually
all right so
um
so one one so one problem is going to be
that this this actually this coordinate
ring of the determinant is pretty large
so okay
um
and uh
okay so so the
the first conjecture actually even
before the one we disproved was that
instead of looking at lambdas which
don't show up in the determinant we can
directly look at lambdas for which their
the upper bound given by the chronic
coefficient is zero
and which show up in the in the
permanent
and that that such such lambdas would
exist and that's
and uh
and this is basically what
what we first what we first described
and this was just purely using
combinatorics of chronic your
coefficients to the extent we actually
know it because as i said we don't
really know that much about chronic your
coefficients to begin with
and in the course in the course of
the study we actually
used complexity theory and geometric
complexity theory we proved an
inequality between chronic cure and
platinum coefficients
which
using representation theory wasn't is
not at all obvious because the
chronicler coefficients and the platysm
coefficients are different
multiplicities of different types of
spaces so there is no
natural map between them or any other
corresponds
okay so
and so and this is this is what
what we the full result that we actually
we we proved with peter
later that if n is greater than or then
if n is greater than or equal to m to
the 25th so basically we cannot prove a
better
uh so this is the law the the only lower
bound we could prove with this
gct method if if at all possible so we
haven't really proved it
but for n greater than or equal to m to
the 25th basically
if if some partition occurs in the
coordinate ring of the orbit closure of
the pattern permanent then it's also
going to occur in the coordinate
training of the orbit closure of the
determinant
and then
we cannot prove a super pulling on a
lower bound this way
okay so
let me
tell you briefly what we did with the
chronicler coefficients uh
without actually having a formula for
the chronic error coefficient so what do
what can we do
well it's not that we don't really know
absolutely anything so there are some
tricks
uh but before that
let's let me just point out where
this embedding uh
uh
is um
the embedding itself is obstructing the
obstruction model in some sense
but uh this was actually the as that's
our result of landsberg that if we
look at this padded homogeneous
polynomials and it doesn't matter that
here it's the permanent of size m it
could be any other
homogeneous polynomial of degree m and
and
m squared variables
then
the only
multiplicities that could show up are
such that uh
lambda 1 has
has many the first part has has many
rows
and actually the majority
this this when this end grows basically
what's growing is the first part of
london it's not it's not anything else
and
and then also the the length of lambda
is determined by the number of variables
that are used in this polynomial so this
is m squared
uh
and uh and also
if we are if we are interested in this
inequality then we need to look for a
large degree
for another so the bigger than n over
and uh
and then and then once we have these
types of conditions
uh
then we can
show that even that uh
just already for n bigger than three and
um to the
fourth
we already have a positive chronic your
coefficient
everywhere we would care about
for these types of partitions
um
and uh and the way the proof goes and
similarly in in a similar fashion it
goes for the other
for the the bigger result is that
in order to prove positivity of certain
multiplicities we we rely heavily on a
few properties
uh so we rely on the fact that
we know that the chronic your
coefficient
of square square and square is greater
than zero and actually
let me
actually there is a
more general results so if we have a
uh
chronic your coefficient of two
partitions where
which are
symmetric so self-conjugate this is
going to be greater than or equal to the
absolute value of the character
of mu and then
the main
the main hook so it's a particular
character evaluation and while the
characters are bad in general in this
particular case
it's this character absolute value is
just one
and
so we have some other nice properties
that we can conjugate to partition the
chronic coefficient remains the same
third property for some special
so we can we can prove
that if we take a chronicler coefficient
with some
particular
so who can then a little bit
any any type of smaller partition here
as long as
this is
uh
positive for some small very small
partition it's going to be always
positive so with the
rectangle and then
basically we use this decomposition the
various positivity rules for smaller
building blocks and the semi group
property which tells us that the chronic
your coefficient
is
of the sum pair of coordinate wise sum
of partitions
is greater than or equal to the maximum
of the two
small the the chronic coefficients of
the first
triple and then and the chronic
coefficient of the second triple as long
as both are
positive
so we can't just
start from nothing so with this
and and in that sense our our partitions
we can cut them cut them up
in various squares and and cook like
things and then we can
also cut to cut up the rectangle in in
in various different ways to compose it
and we get positivity
and just briefly to tell you the other
so the other result that i promised how
to use the
geometric complexity theory to prove the
inequality between
platism and chronic your coefficients
so so this is
the platism is just the multiplicity of
london the symmetric deet power in the
symmetric and power
or in other words
this is going to be the multiplicity of
lambda
in the coordinate ring of the orbit
closure of all polynomials of the of n
in n variables of degree d
so this is
and the other
and the other one is the chronicler
coefficient which
is described in terms of the symmetric
group representation but it's also
an upper bound for the determinant
of report so we have
we have this inequality between these
two different types of quantities
how does it work
again so in this this inequality holds
when the first row is growing
and uh
so
basically if this is our partition meal
and our partition lambda is adding
uh
b times n minus m boxes so this is going
to be the big partition lambda
when we do this not many things change
that that's basically
the idea
first of all
um
this uh so there is again the kaddish
landsberg result
basically says that if we look at this
orbit closure vm is all polynomials in m
squared variables
of degree n
then uh
almost by definition this is going to be
greater than or equal to this platinum
coefficient
uh we also have certain stability
results so when we keep
increasing the rectangles and just
adding
partitions to the to
just adding squares to the first row of
the partition we
eventually it stabilizes
and
and now comes the
complexity theory so basically the
complexity theory
geometric complexity here it tells you
that if the multiplicity
of lambda here is greater than the
chronic error
which is now greater than the
multiplicity in the determinant orbit
closure it
means that something here some
polynomial here cannot be represented as
an n by n determinant of
a fine linear forms
so this space is larger than what you
can get
with determinants of size and by n
and this means that
there is some polynomial with these
properties over here for which the
determinant of complexity is bigger than
n
because and n is the size of the
determinant
okay so
and now we just argue by a contradiction
so if
if uh
if our uh
platinum coefficient is bigger than the
chronic your coefficient then in
particular it means that the
multiplicity lambda in this ring is
greater than the chronic error
coefficient then so then bigger than the
multiplicity in the determinant ring
which
is this delta which means that there
exists some
polynomial of uh
degree m and m squared variables
which has the terminal complexity bigger
than n but we know this stability is
telling us that we can take and go to
infinity
and we always look we always find a
polynomial with
determinant of complexity bigger than
arbitrary large n which is not true
because
we know these are polynomials of degree
m and
m squared variables they
can be computed with whatever
m to them squared at most operations or
determinant so determinant of complexity
is actually bounded for this polynomials
right
foreign
by adding
some some other other parts so
it's uh
yeah it's i mean it needs to be proven
so i just the same in my intuition that
we we don't exactly know but we
in some sense we can track how this the
numbers change
and well then he was not just one long
road
can you
encode that embedding and like you're
saying you're wondering worry about
using other aesthetics if you use it
could you write it as a permanent with
the padding building of something
i mean so okay so
so in some sense we are not using that
well we are using the the fact that the
embedding is of this
of this form but there is nothing
specific about the permanent that we use
beyond this point so everything else
that we do
is on the level of the determinant and
saying of what what things can be
represented with an end by android the
determinant essentially
there's
[Music]
yeah i mean that's right
that's so the fact that it's the
permanent over there
is not not crucial here
okay so
me uh
okay so
um
so
so the chronic coefficient as
uh as we
we're just saying so they they are
they go with the characterization and
the determinant
uh now if you're asking for different
types of computational models let's say
iterated matrix multiplication so
you can still apply this paradigm and
you're going to get some com some
multiplicities which are
upper bounded by various combinations of
chronic your little wood richardson and
platysm coefficient so in any case
they they will they will still show up
and in that sense it's still important
to see how large these chronicler
coefficients can go and now
let me just tell you a little bit about
the optimization part so if this is a
workshop on symmetry and optimization
where are the
optimization questions so the first
thing
here we have a very
easy combinatorial problem
count the number of partitions which fit
inside an l by m rectangle
uh and obviously the size of the
partition goes at most up to l times m
these are the
generating function is just the q
binomial coefficient
and it's uh it's
actually a pretty hard theorem of
sylvester using who is using lee
algebras
to show that he pro to to prove that
these numbers are unimodal so weakly
increasing and then decreasing
and the whole issue comes from the
restriction inside this rectangle if you
just try to prove it
simply by adding boxes here and there
you'll see that
it's not so easy
um so what this has to do with the
chronic here is this uh this identity is
that the chronic error of rectangle
rectangle and just two rows so
we're again back to that setting we were
studying for the determinant rectangle
and rectangle
and this is just the
consecutive
differences
between these numbers that that
show up here so in particular because
the chronic your coefficient is
non-negative you get an inequality
between these numbers
and uh
and using properties this semi-group
property of the chronic coefficients and
this character bound we were actually
able to show that these differences
has this this exponential bound
and later
we actually with probabilistic methods
we were able to to study
this difference independently so we
actually
know exactly the title symptotics for
this particular value so this is
maybe the the only instance of
non-trivial various of chronic
coefficients where we know the tight
asymptotics and here what comes here is
something
really actually pretty horrible so i'm
not going to go into details but
there isn't there is an answer to to
that question
and now from then on
what what can we say
and
we can start with the most general
question of what are the maximal
possible values that the chronicle
coefficient can take or little wood
richardson for that matter
and uh
and this is this is a theorem of richard
stanley that the the maximal chronic
your coefficient if we go over all
possible triples of partitions is on the
order of square root of n factorial
and um and the maximum little wood
richardson coefficient
is exponential
in n
and now the question is can we find for
which partitions lambda mu and mu this
maxima are achieved so can we actually
show any non-trivial lower bound
uh
and uh
so we
uh we looked at this problem
a little bit so we can we can say
something and this is that
if the chronicler coefficient is gonna
be large then
uh then these partitions will have to
have a very specific
shape in the limit and this is
shape that looks like this
essentially so this is what we call the
version care of log and ship
limit which is the typical
partition which we get under the plunger
l measure or in other words
weighted by the dimension of the
irreducible representation
and
and in that case so this is
that the number the number of standard
young tableau or this is the dimension
of the reducible representation also
this is actually
on the order of square root of n
factorial and then you have
some
compensating factor of this order of
square root of n
and
and most and we know that partitions
which which have a large
large dimension so the representation
has a large dimension they are going to
be close to that shape
so this is
this is the basically that the theorem
has two parts first suppose that
we have a sequence of partitions which
goes to this this very large
the largest possible value that the
chronic here can have then
these partitions will have to have
this shape
and and on the other hand if we have two
such partitions then there exists a
third one such that
we can find a large chronicler
coefficient but which one exactly
no no idea
and uh and again so in terms of the
maximal dimension we actually have
various
types of bounds
which is where where we
we get this this theorem from
uh
and uh
so what
what other bounds can we get
and uh
so here is a bound that that looks
pretty large
so depending on which regime we use for
the sizes of the partitions
then we
then this bound can be meaningful so for
example
in the so in this case we have a small
number of rows but still not so
certainly not constant
and
so for example in this in this example
we basically have
l by l squared and our
total size is just l
l cubed
and in this case
we have an exponential upper bound so
not the square root of n factorial that
i was showing earlier which is much
bigger
and
and since since this is workshop on
optimization let me just tell you very
briefly how we prove this and we prove
this
using contingency arrays so contingency
arrays are
uh in this case three-dimensional so
these are
three-dimensional arrays so three
coordinates i j and k
and uh
the marginals the
uh
two-dimensional marginals are going to
be given by this by the partitions
lambda mu and mu
so again it's similar to what matthias
was talking about so this is a
marginal problem on this array
and then we have this this identity so
if we sum over all
lambda mu and mu chronic your
coefficient and then this so the sure
function you can think of just the
reducible geom
representations and these are gonna be
the the characters but in any case these
are polynomials with
positive coefficients so that's all we
care about
this uh then this is uh this is the
generating function for this contingency
arrays in when we write this in terms of
monomials
and then and now we just uh expand this
in terms of monomials as i said here we
have positive monomers
then we are going to get that the little
wood richardson coefficient is bounded
by the number of
marginal problems or contingency arrays
and now for them we apply
the symptotic results that uh
sasha barvinok developed for
counting contingency tables and
for these three-dimensional contingency
tables
with given marginals
this number is
is upper bounded
or the logarithm of this number would be
upper bounded by the maximal of this
this function
which is a
con
concave function over this poly top over
here so we can
find some max
some maximum which is
depending if we if we take symmetric
marginal so if all these lambda beta and
gamma have the same values
and we know that the maximum is going to
be in the middle
and we can at least calculate this limit
and
and there is the for for in terms of
lower bounds we have
some very a few strange examples but
very far from anything
explicitly close to the to the exponent
and
this is where i will stop since i'm out
of time
thank you very much
this compare during those contingency
tables there are some local chemical
results
uh
sometimes it's the other way around we
can improve some low concavity as well
choosing
there are no results and opposites say
you look and keep it using more
algebraic
or like some
polynomial ideas like complexity or
whatever and you transfer that result to
that something like that exists uh
there may be but um so we haven't
applied it so we should maybe tell me
more what kind of results there are and
i'll see if if
it gives us anything
so but then so definitely it's
the study of this uh contingency tables
is uh
is very related to all of this
other questions
online audience anything
um
i am wondering what the
do you think could help at all to get a
sharp p formula for the kronecker
coefficients using this contingency
table description i mean this is the
thing that i've been using all the all
this time so far and
when you
problem with the contingency tables is
that the formula you get in the end for
just single chronic your position is
still an alternating
some of the contingency arrays so it
might be better than the characters but
still
you have to find some involution
for this contingency or race to cancel
it and is
no no side to toe no way of doing this
not an approach
if i remember there's still like a kind
of
approach using the actual highest
weights uh for
you know
coming up with obstructions
um
do you think that uh
problems related to these ones still
could arise there or do you think that
that's more helpful
uh
so what do you what do you mean to use
just construct something to construct i
guess like a
uh
an actual polynomial on which they were
placed
yeah okay
i mean sure so if you can do this but
it's very hard
it seems to be harder than just finding
the spaces
[Music]
i actually have one
[Music]
[Music]
uh no and this would be very interesting
because that was my idea like
yeah because that is vnp also yeah and
it has more interesting structure
[Music]
yeah we should we should discuss this so
yeah
that's a few more questions